levine is the queen
of pop punk spunk
because you just have so much fun i'm
gonna get a t-shirt made that says
shania says avril lavigne is the queen
of pop punk spawn the queen of country
pop reunites with the queen of pop punk
on the latest episode of home now radio
on apple music hits shania twain is
joined by fellow canadian avril lavigne
who thanks the artist for helping her
get discovered in her small hometown in
ontario as an early teen
we heard an opportunity on the radio
station to sing with you just come on
come on over to us win a chance to sing
with shania on stage and i happened to
win that
met you
14 years old and i can't thank you
enough for that opportunity because that
was so life-changing for me celebrating
20 years since the release of her debut
album unplugged
[Music]
avril shares her excitement for her
forthcoming seventh record love sucks
out on february 25th
i took a little break a little down time
for a minute and then you know and now
i'm back with this album and i'm like
it's nice because like
at this point i definitely can say like
i'm not doing it because i have to or i
feel like i need to i'm really doing it
because i want to and it's fun and this
making this record was so much fun also
fun for the juno award winner listening
to shania's 1997 come on over album
which avril calls one of the best albums
of all time
man i feel like a woman
i know every single song
all the lyrics and every video because
every song
was a single was it not like it was
crazy most of the songs on that album
were yeah
it was it was i mean that's exhausting
it was exhausting
i didn't really experience it in the
moment you know i was um it was a bit of
a whirlwind now i'm enjoying it more
like 25 years later that don't impress
me much
and rightly so avril says that decades
later she still rocks out to those hit
songs i'll totally have a shania rock
out day where i'll be like cooking and
put like your album on
and um that's just
amazing songwriting and your music
connected with people
you